[Music]
it's time for bed where did those boys
go off to where are they
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to the famous from mom and
dad we mean a lot of nerf gun yeah let's
go boys where are you always those boys
aren't getting ready for bed
there you are I told you guys to get
ready for bed and now you're down here
playing you go get ready for bed or
you're in deep trouble if you shoot me
with that nerf gun you're gonna go into
a timeout and never come out
[Music]
look II saw yeah my guess who woulda no
fun
that wasn't what he saw
[Applause]
hey Luke here with younger boys YouTube
channel today I'm gonna show you how to
make a knife sheath out of a dead
squirrel back is the trouble time to
bring the pain spear spear spear axe axe
axe axe axe gun hog splitter here we go
this is what we need
[Music]
oh they're better armed than I thought I
got a plan though we need leverage cease
fire cease fire
I've got Mimi come to bed or Mimi gets
it Tommy Tommy do what she says she's
crazy
don't worry Nathan I got a plan let's
stamp or take a [ __ ] it'd be up Jacob
Jacob don't worry babe I think I could
get the shot
Oh hold on I got an idea hey Tommy look
what I've got
he's got my fishing reel do what he says
do what he says oh he will gets it let's
not get crazy guys let's do a prisoner
exchange okay take a baby Oh Jacob uh do
[Music]
all right guys enough of these games
it's time you two into bed
that didn't work
I've got a new plan Becca where to use
stealth you can't see something I think
there's a sniper in the room let me see
I can't see anyone what are we going to
do Tommy don't worry I got it
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah I think I see a buck
[Music]
alright back at these little Rugrats
need to go to bed
you tried frontal assault and that
didn't work so I got a new idea I need
you to do a distraction do it bedtime
for Bonzo
alright guys it's bedtime it's like this
every night if you have trouble putting
your kids of it make sure you click
subscribe for more tips tutorials and
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel if you liked this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button and
you'll get notifications thanks for
watch